it's great to be joined today by Robert
Zubrin who's an aerospace engineer
author and also one of the driving
forces behind the Mars direct project
which is a proposal to reduce both the
cost and complexity of a mission to Mars
so Robert let's just start at sort of
the top other proposals to go to Mars in
what ways are they more complex than
maybe they need to be well the classic
example of an over complex program was
the NASA 90-day report which said before
we can go to Mars we had to build a
space station we had to build hangars on
the space station we had to build a
lunar base we had to develop advanced
propulsion we had to somehow use the
lunar base in support of the advanced
propulsion spaceships that would be
built at the space station and so forth
ah now and that created a 30-year
timeline and a 400 billion dollar price
tag now NASA recently topped that by
coming up with a new idea which they
hadn't even hit on in the 98 report
which is that they want to build a space
station in moon orbit to the purpose of
which is there is no purpose for which
and uh so basically in the 90-day report
they were really spending money in order
to give everyone's pet program a role in
in the plan uh it's like rewriting
Shakespeare's plays to give everyone in
the school apart um but in this case um
frankly they weren't spending money to
do things at all they were just doing
things to spend money and talk to us
about when we think about the Mars
direct proposal and we'll dig into some
of the details in the different phases
and aspects of it
one of the most notable aspects of it to
me is that it does not require the
development of any new technology that
we don't currently have access to is
that right well no new fundamental
technology there
certainly new pieces of hardware in it
heavy with booster a large Mars Lander
and so forth but there you know we're
not talking Los Alamos 1943 here we are
venturing into new realms of physics
we're talking about taking our craft of
aerospace engineering and applying it to
design larger things things better
backed up and so forth than what we've
already built but things of the same
kind and so the first thing I would say
about Mars direct is number one its
orientation which is that it's mission
driven we're not trying to give everyone
apart in the play we're not trying to
run our business to please our vendors
okay we are trying to get to Mars and we
want to actually do it with as few
critical technologies as few vendors as
possible not with the maximum number
okay so so there's that that it is
simply a much fairer approach that is
the mentality behind it is we're doing
the mission to do the mission not to
make a bunch of people happy by giving
them a part in the mission second thing
is the actual approach itself which
makes use of Martian resources
it was our philosophy in designing the
Mars direct plan that the very things
that make Mars interesting can also be
what makes it attainable that is how
exploration on earth has been supported
in the past you know in our Lewis and
Clark never could across America 27 men
unless they hunted their way across they
obviously used local water local air in
some cases they traded with Native
Americans for resources but in all cases
they were using the resources present in
the environment that they were operating
in if they had attempted to bring all
their food water and air they would have
needed a wagon train of supplies for
every man and for every horse so then
they would have needed further wagon
trains for all the men and horses and
the wagon trains and on and on it would
have been an impossible mission and
Robert the way that if I understand
correctly the way that that concept
relates to your proposal is that we
would actually use your
plan would use Martian resources for the
return back to earth is that correct
that is correct that is the way the
mission works is first we shoot an earth
return vehicle to Mars we can do that
with one launch of a heavy lift vehicle
that goes in it lands on Mars unfilled
it then makes its return fuel
automatically out of the Martian
atmosphere which is carbon dioxide and
water we can turn carbon dioxide and
water into methane that's just natural
gases good fuel and oxygen which is the
oxidizer to burn the fuel so once you
have a fully fueled earthly turned
vehicle waiting for you on Mars then you
shoot the crew out to Mars and once
again that's a one-way launch one launch
of a heavy-lift booster it goes in at
lamps new the earth in turn vehicle they
use the habitat that they fly to Mars in
as their house on Mars their base on
Mars at the end of the year and a half
of exploring on Mars they get in the
earth return vehicle may fly home each
time you do this you add another habitat
to the base and before you know it
you've built the beginning of the first
human settlement on a new world there's
nothing in this that's fundamentally
beyond our technology that's a pretty
brief explanation of the plan if people
want to know in great detail I have a
whole book on the subject called
the case for Mars in the book the case
for Mars you talk not only about sort of
the the approach from a technical
standpoint but also you make the case
for why it would be important to go to
Mars so in your estimation what is
interesting about Mars what are the
reasons to go to Mars well there's three
reasons to go to Mars um there's the
science there's challenge and there's
the future um the science is finding out
whether we're alone in the universe Mars
was once a warm and wet planet if it's
true that life evolves out of chemistry
wherever it has the right kind of
environment Mars had that environment
the environments on Mars and Earth were
essentially the same in the period that
life first appeared on earth so if life
appears out of chemistry wherever you
have the correct conditions like water
freezing to ice on a cold night it
happens for sure okay uh then life
should have appeared on Mars and if
that's the case then life is all over
the universe and since we now know the
basic laws of evolution
drive life to develop more complex more
capable more active forms together
capable of more activity intelligence
ever more rapid evolution if life's
everywhere it means intelligences
everywhere it means we're not alone on
the other hand if we go tomorrow as we
find out that despite the fact that they
had very similar conditions to the
primitive earth no life appeared there
that can mean that the origin of life on
earth was a one in a trillion chance
shot and you know it's like winning the
lottery how do you know whether you've
won the lottery and you have never
spoken to anyone else outside of your
house how do you know whether that's a
sure bet that everyone experiences or
whether you were one in a billion
okay if you go check with your neighbor
and they've also won the lottery you can
assume that it's a pretty common
experience on the other hand if you
check around the neighborhood and no one
else has ever won the lottery you'd say
gee I'm pretty lucky yeah I'll say so
there's the science um now uh then
there's the challenge you know I think
humans are are like societies are like
individuals we grow we challenge
ourselves we statement we don't humans
to Mars program be tremendous positive
bracing challenge to every society that
participates particularly to the youth
it would say to every young person learn
your science you can be a pioneer in new
worlds out of that challenge we get
millions of young scientists engineers
inventors technological entrepreneurs
medical researchers the works uh these
are the kind of people that drive to
society if you want to create
intellectual capital the way you do it
is by challenging you snot but youth not
by brutalizing them with a perpetual
testing which is apparently what
Washington thinks can work um and then
finally there's the future I mean really
if we do this then five hundred years
from now there'll be new branches of
human civilization not only on Mars but
on thousands of planets orbiting stars
in this region of the galaxy and when
they look back at this time what will
they consider is important when we look
back 500 years what do we consider
important you ask any American what
happened in 1492 its Christopher
Columbus
nobody says well in 1492 the board she
has took over the PACA sea which they
did and that would have been the big
headliner
it has been big-time newspapers in 1492
England France signed a peace treaty in
1492 who knows that okay you know lots
of things happened to 1492 that no one
today
cares about or knows about but Columbus
matters to us because he made us
possible okay and similarly you know
five hundred years from now nobody's
going to care which gang of thugs came
out on top in Syria you know or you know
who won or who lost various political
gang warfare fights uh but what we did
to make the future spacefaring
civilization of humanity possible that's
what's going to matter okay that I mean
this time will be remembered because
this is when we first set sail for other
worlds Robert I want to touch a little
bit on the sort of psychological and
sociological aspects of the mission to
go you know back a little bit down into
the micro uh question one which we just
haven't touched on yet is how long would
with the trip to Mars be but once you've
answered that which I know you'll be
able to do in very short order talk to
me a little bit about the expected
psychological and sociological issues
that might come up in terms of a
duration with this level of isolation a
small group of people for a year and a
half on Mars plus the travel time well
the flight plan is six months out year
and a half on the surface six months
back so two and a half years away from
Earth but only six months traveling to
Mars one way and uh now that's a
standard rotation on the space station
people do that all the time and people
done much rougher things in the past we
look and Frank and her family were in an
attic for two and a half years
surrounded by Nazis and those were
ordinary people chosen by circumstances
not chosen for maximum psychological you
know toughness or anything of the sort
so people can deal with this and they
have dealt with much tougher stuff than
this I think the human factors problem
of a human Mars mission is extremely
over drawn in what particular way what
aspect of it do you think is getting
maybe more attention than it deserves
well I think up
you know first of all there's been some
studies where they take some people who
with limited selection put them in a
habitat for in case for one case in
Moscow for 500 days with nothing to do
that's an isolation study you put people
in a newspaper office with nothing to do
in a month you Cho pathologies okay but
the but a Mars mission is not going to
have nothing to do Mars missions going
to have all kinds of great stuff to do
they're going to be exploring a new
world but you know I mean really uh the
problem they're going to have at the
AMPA psychological problem will be
overworked because they're going to be
driving themselves to try to accomplish
the maximum they can in the limited
amount of time they have on Mars which
has been provided to them at enormous
expense by society so and you know we
actually see this ourselves the Mars
Society has to practice Mars bases one
in the desert one in the Arctic and we
tasked them to do programs of
exploration and these are scientists
they want to be there they're not like
maybe crews in Antarctica that are
exiled who want to really be in San
Diego on the waterfront
you know where they can go to nightclubs
on the weekend leave I mean no these are
people in their element and they're
explorers and they want to be there they
would devote their careers for a chance
to be there and uh and they also know
all I know that if they make it back
they're made people you know that
they're going to get put on corporate
boards they're going to have advertising
endorsements we'll be rich um you know
Apollo astronauts a lot of people they
would write checks people to even cast
their checks they want to keep the check
so they have their autograph huh uh uh
and so there you have it um and uh so I
just don't buy it I mean you know in
World War two millions of Americans were
away from home for three years you know
eating crap food and then sitting in
muddy trenches and you know brutalized
by 90-day wonders and and and and you
know drill sergeants and and with Nazis
or Japanese trying to kill them and and
you know they handled it this is a walk
in the park compared to that well
Robert last thing I want to touch on
given all of the proposals that are
currently sort of out there given what
we know about the different proposed
timelines of different projects what's
your best guess as to what year a human
will first step foot on Mars I think
that we can do it in the late 2020s from
a technical point of view we can be on
Mars in eight years of what it takes is
the will right now I'm seeing more will
from SpaceX than from NASA although NASA
frankly is better equipped to do it they
have much more resources but where
there's a will there's a way and where
there's not a will there's not a way
we've been speaking with Robert Zubrin
the Mars direct project he is an
aerospace engineer and author of
fascinating Robert thanks so much for
talking to us today thank you